Добрый день, добрый вечер, доброе утро сегодня у меня гость Энтони.
Энтони американец и говорить по русский и говорить очень хорошо
Я не знаю, для меня это впервые. Ну как это сказать, это отличная возможность и удовольствие встретить Энтони
Я всегда говорю это на английском языке, если вам нравится мой канал, пожалуйста, включите уведомление и подпишитесь на канал.
Хорошо, Энтони. Почему ты… мы же можем на ты да? Да.
Почему ты говоришь по русский?
Почему я говорю по русский? Да. Потому что я выучил русский язык.
Русский язык очень богатый, очень красивый язык а в Америке на западе у нас есть такой стереотип что русский язык очень сложный и невозможно выучить русский язык.
Грамматика слишком сложная, никто не говорить по русский в Америке, но это не факт это на самом деле наоборот есть много людей которые говорят по русский в Америке.
Да. И на самом деле русская грамматика не так уж и сложна на самом деле можно выучить русский без грамматики.
Ну можно изучать грамматику, но я честно не помню, что я открывал учебник и изучал русскую грамматику типа грамматические правила.
Я изучал русский потому что я скачал несколько приложений, я встретил русских людей и разговаривал с ними
Я даже смотрел детские каналы на русском языке, я смотрел мультфильмы на русском языке.
Я думаю, что это очень полезно изучать язык по мультфильмам и это должно быть понятно.
Да, но я согласен с тобой и не согласен.
Давай, с чем ты не согласен?
Так я не согласен потому что я думаю, что русский язык очень сложный.
Сложный с точки зрения грамматики. Да.
Потому что я учил много языков, и я думаю, что славянские языки слишком сложные и есть много правил.
Но я согласен с тобой что не стоит сосредоточиваться на грамматике.
Я начал изучать русский, когда мне было 60 лет. Вау.
Да, и я решил изучать русский язык потому что другие люди мне сказали, что это невозможно.
Потому что я изучал китайский, японский и так далее. В азиатских языках грамматика не очень сложная, очень прагматическая, но я не хочу сказать, что очень простая они не очень сложные как славянские языки.
И я решил попробовать. Но я должен сказать, что я не люблю смотреть мультфильмы.
Но все равно я больше всего привык изучать языки через чтения, через слушание.
Я иногда смотрю правила потому что иногда в моем мозге возникает вопрос «почему?».
Но я думаю, что если взять все, то время которое я использовал для изучение русского языка то изучение грамматики может быть заняло 3%.
Да я согласен 3%.
Почему люди северной Америке, Америке, Канаде должны изучать русский язык и в чем привлекательность русского языка?
Ну я думаю, что русский язык, во-первых, это очень важный язык. Может быть русский язык не так важен в Америке, но, например, в центральной Азии большинство людей говорят на русском
В Казахстане, в Узбекистане, в Таджикистане в Армении тоже многие говорят по русский. В Украине, в Беларуси даже в Эстонии на восточной части Эстонии многие говорят на русском.
И я люблю путешествовать, я люблю встречать новых людей, я люблю общаться с людьми и когда я поеду в Россию, в Казахстан ...
На самом деле я путешествовал в Украину несколько месяцев назад и знание русского языка это действительно помогает в путешествии.
Это позволить тебе познакомится с большим количеством людей.
Конечно, и где ты был в Украине?
Я был в Киеве и Львове.
Я изучал украинский и когда я был во Львове я говорил по украинский, но я думаю, что все во Львове говорят по русский.
Да это правда они понимают русский язык, но забавно что они понимают тебя, но они отвечают тебе на украинском языке почти всегда.
Но знание русского языка помогает в изучении других славянских языков.
Я чуть-чуть понимал, когда они говорили на украинском потому что я знаю русский.
Да конечно, я был в Киеве и Днепре и там все говорят по русский.
Ничего себе. Я думаю, что привлекательность русского языка — это то что Россия — это огромная территория и во время советского союза была еще больше.
Да. Огромная история, огромная литература и огромная как это сказать мастерство во спорте, в искусстве и много чего...
Поэтому это великая богатство и для меня это привлекательность.
С точки зрения бизнеса может быть меньше, на сегодняшний день все хотят изучать китайский.
Китайский, например, да. Или же в северной Америки или в Канаде хотят изучать французский.
Испанский тоже. Да, но все равно чем больше мы изучаем русский мы, тем больше чувствуем эту привлекательность и это богатство.
Поэтому я думаю, что это того стоит. Да, даже если никто не говорить на этом языке и даже если это бесполезный язык изучение языка помогает нашему мозгу.
Это на самом деле, я читал онлайн и узнал, что изучение языка уменьшает как сказать на русском ...
Это может помочь тебе избавиться от болезни Альцгеймера.
Да, от болезней стариков. Да это правда.
Я думаю, что мы использовали более или менее похожие методы для изучения русского языка.
Ты можешь сказать по больше конкретнее что ты делал и когда ты был в России, Украине или в Эстонии как было твоё путешествие?
Более конкретно, как и каким образом я изучал русский? Да.
Сначала я изучал самые популярные и распространённые слова, например: вода, дерево, дверь...
И я писал примеры как я открываю дверь, закрываю дверь, но когда я уже знал 100 слов или 200 я начал читать короткие рассказы, короткий текст
Я использовал твой сайт и на самом деле до сих пор я использую ссылку для изучения греческого и немецкого
Я всегда упоминаю твой сайт на своём канале.
Хорошо, греческий интересно... я не знаю ты использовал наши мини сказки и мини истории. Да мини истории.
Да, но я думаю, что греческий очень здорово и хорошо. Во всяком случаи похоже, похоже...
Я смотрю онлайн видео Стивена Крашена, и он говорил, что есть очень отличный метод который называется TPRS. Да.
Я нашёл канал может быть ты его знаешь «Русский с Максом»?
Да я знаю. Да и он преподаёт русский и там все ясно, он говорить ясно, медленно и понятно и это действительно помогает и действительно полезно.
Я помню, что после 9 месяцев я уже говорил по русский я понимал почти весь видео, когда он говорил по русский.
Так что чтение и слушание я думаю, что на 70 % даже на 80 % речи и то что ты читаешь должно быть понятным, и я думаю, что да...
Когда встречается незнакомое слова нужно записать и подчеркнуть это слова и после чтение можешь повторить это слова..
Я думаю, что это так. У меня есть несколько вопросов.
Русский язык для меня открыл дверь на другой мир славянских языков таких как чешский, украинский, польский и это весь славянский мир, русский мир…
Это очень-очень интересно и это большая часть истории. Я изучал романские языки как итальянский, испанский, немецкий или азиатские языки
Но славянские языки — это очень полезно, и они интересные для меня.
Да и на самом деле всего тысячу лет назад все славянские люди говорили на древнем языке, на древнем славянском языке.
Мы точно не знаем, но может быть. Я не знаю, но я думаю, что церковь имел важную роль на развитие всех славянских языков.
Да, очень интересно, и музыка и все...Я был в России и в Украине и очень ...
Я имею ввиду если ты можешь быть вместе с людьми этих стран, они принимают тебя если ты можешь говорить по русский. Да.
Если ты не говоришь по русский они будут дружелюбными, но это не то же самое
Да русские они очень удивляются, когда слушают тебя «О американец говорить по русский»
«Вау, почему именно русский? Почему ты так решил? Почему не итальянский или немецкий? Почему именно русский?»
Потому что все уже изучают немецкий, итальянский, а я хочу изучать русский.
Это уникальный язык, это что-то другое.
Например, в Америке все учат французский, например, и я тоже изучал французский и я говорю на французском.
Но я не хотел изучать другие романские или латинские языки как итальянский.
Я хотел чего-то нового, например, русский, славянский язык.
И почему в северной Америки, Канаде, США люди не изучают русский?
Во-первых, я думаю, что потому что есть такое ощущение как мы все ещё живём в холодном войне, Россия или русский язык...
Почему ты учишь русский язык? Почему русский? Я не знаю может есть такой стереотип, но всего лишь прошло 30 лет после советского союза и это мало
Все ещё существует такой стереотип что «О русский, о Россия»
И да потому что русскоговорящих людей в Америке мало и в Канаде.
Конечно есть в Нью Йорке и Брайтон Бич есть много русскоговорящих людей.
Но я думаю, что американцы и канадцы они изучают больше всего французский и испанский язык чем русский.
Я думаю, что один из причин...
Для нас в Канаде и в Америке есть такое ощущение что Россия немножко закрыта.
Не легко достать визу и для них тоже также
Но, например, японская культура, корейская культура которые более далеко от нас и к русской культуре.
Но очень легко дойти до Японии, работать в Японии и встретится с людьми...
В России есть немного этого ощущения. Может быть из-за советского союза или сегодняшней политической ситуации. Это я думаю, что очень... Сложнее может быть?
Нет, печально потому что когда я был в России они очень были открытыми, но есть такое ощущение...
Я думаю, что есть уровень между государствами и к сожалению, это существует.
Поэтому русская литература не так популярна, как это должно быть.
Да, например, Россия закрыта для нас, и Америка и Канада закрыты для них.
Например, нужно получить визу чтобы поехать в Америку или в Канаду. Так что это политика которая мешает…
Например, тоже, когда ты изучаешь русский ... «А как ты относишься к президенту России?»
У меня нету по этому поводу никакого мнения, мне все равно я просто хочу выучить русский и говорить с русскими людьми я не хочу говорить о политике.
Но мы должны надеется на лучшее. Да.
Я думаю, что если, например, русская музыка и традиционная музыка которую мы знаем балалайка, но и существует русский поп.
Я ничего не знаю о русском попе, но немецкий поп, корейский поп мы знаем, но русский поп или рэп мы не знаем.
Ну молодых людей которые знают корейский поп мы знаем, но про русский ничего мы не знаем.
Мы должны надеется на лучшее. Да и изучение языка это открывает наш мозг.
Сейчас я уважаю русских, я уважаю и люблю Россию, а раньше я думал все в России живут бедно, все обманщики и мошенники, но это не правда.
Есть разные стереотипы, например, о Китае, Италии, но когда ты изучаешь язык ты понимаешь, что большинство стереотипов не верные.
Но в Канаде мы знаем, что русские очень хорошо играют в хоккей. А в хоккей, да.
Мы любим играть в хоккей с Россией. У нас в Ванкувере есть один игрок из России и ещё один из Беларуси.
Ну что же, очень интересно было спасибо большое.
Спасибо тебе.
Я хочу улучшить мой уровень русского потому что я забыл и сейчас я занимаюсь и другими языками.
Ничего страшного ты хорошо говоришь по русский.
Хорошо, спасибо.
С удовольствием. До встречи.
До встречи.